he always told me hey you can't buy you
can't buy it unless you could pay cash
for like that kind of attitude so where
did that mindset change because if you
look at the americans that came out of
the depression that air that they grew
up in that area they're all about
minimal right living so i think that
once america goes through this just just
a tip of the iceberg we're going to go
back to that same methodology i can
actually answer that question when it
changed 1978 the community reinvestment
act fannie mae freddie mac started
student loans government-backed student
loans government-backed housing
that's what started the free credit
spigot and it's only gotten worse from
there all right and credit cards came
before that well diners cars diners
clubs all diners club exactly but you
had to what you had to do to get a
credit card back in the day was insane
the credit you want to talk about income
inequality in the world credit score you
know nobody ever talks about this ever
you've never seen anybody march against
credit right isn't that crazy nobody's
ever marched against visa nobody's ever
marched against mastercard there's never
been a occupy discover credit score is
the largest wealth disparity in the
world the wealthier you are the more
access to funds you have if you're if
you're not wealthy or if you've
struggled and you need the money they
won't give it to you but you know listen
part of that also it's really really
genius it's really genius why they went
to education first especially when you
look at the fact that they got rid of uh
you know like scores to get into higher
education now there's no testing in a
lot of high schools they're getting rid
of the s.a.t
higher education
is not about intellect anymore it's 100
about obedience and the longer you go in
education the more you're willing to put
up with it's more of an obedience test
if you get your phd with a state school
you may not have ever been in the top
echelon of your class you just stayed in
school now think of the brilliance of
that the brilliance of having people
literally pay to do work instead of
getting paid to do work for 10 years and
our society looks at them as if they're
the valiant our society looks at a
trucker a cdl about to make 250 grand
this year as if he gave up on life he
looks at somebody that enlisted in the
military as like last ditch right but
somebody that doesn't earn anything that
pays money to do work there's somebody
noble they get a name they're a doctor
they're appealing well there's the flip
side to the story is that they actually
have to enter the working world at age
35 and then they get paid hopefully a
quarter million dollars a half a million
dollars how's that working out people
with masters and basket weaving well
obviously some people don't think ahead
of the roi of what you're going to go to
school for no clearly but there's
there's i believe there's a longer
strategy
i think there's two things i think
there's two things i think there's those
who maybe are
evil
motivations that they have
let's just say there's a group like that
i think it's a very small community i
don't think it's as big of a community
as a small community but they've got a
lot of power yeah you know i i'm not
disagreeing i'm just telling you it's a
very small community that
is actually trying to do that to ruin
the western westernized philosophy
capitalism the rich all that other stuff
i think there's a flip side of it where
sometimes you do something in your life
and you didn't count all the
possibilities of negative things that
could happen and you're going to pay
some consequence suffer some
consequences and that's what's happening
right now today's a byproduct of bad
policies today's a bad bad uh byproduct
of uh
you know falling for the trap of let's
keep giving people free money today's a
byproduct of getting people not to go to
work and say no they need three more
months they need six more months keep
sending them money
money we're talking we're talking about
this right now and our transportation
czar is at home
yeah two two month uh uh
paternity leave two month paternity
leave uh which which
anyways two-month paternity leave uh is
what they're going through while we just
had a baby did you take maternity leave
then the day i had it i was working so
but that's a different story i don't
have the luxury of being an educated
smart guy like pete you know i i i don't
have the fancy degree yeah it's very
very
i don't have that luxury anyways going
back to it byproduct bad policies
manipulators be on closed doors sure
small community bad policies would
produce this kind of a uh environment
that we currently have i don't know i
don't hate the manipulators pad i got to
be honest that's their job this is what
they want to do right this is they want
to take over the world they want fair
okay that's what they want what i
who i actually hates a strong word who i
who i who i really blame
i blame the useful idiot i blame the
person that goes along with the
manipulators because they just want to
fit in they don't actually look into
anything they don't they don't look at
anything other than a completely
superficial understanding of what's
happening and they want to tweet
something so their favorite celebrity
retweets them they want they want to put
social pressure on a nurse that she has
to choose a single mother nurse has to
choose between putting something in her
body that she doesn't want or losing her
job and not being able to feed her kid
the people that are pressuring her right
into doing the quote unquote right thing
those are the people i can't stand not
the manipulators at the top because
you're right it's very very very few of
them but they they manipulate the masses
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]